mon travail pour voler mes garçons à l'âge adulte je les ai
laissé tomber tu peux trouver de l'eau mais tu
ne peux même pas trouver tes propres enfants donc
il est vivant je ne sais pas mais tu es à la maison
oops une nécessité d'où je viens si
je nous sortais  de date je ne suis pas venu ici
pour faire du tourisme
je suis déjà globalement la bataille de
Gallipoli est iconographique dans notre culture
elle est souvent considérée comme la forge qui a
formé les nations vraiment vous savez pour
la première fois les Australiens et les Néo-
Zélandais se battaient sous leur  propre
drapeau au lieu d'être une extension ou une
colonie de l'Empire britannique et il y a
aussi l'aspect de pouvoir avoir
l'opportunité de mettre devant les
Australiens et les Néo-Zélandais une
perspective qu'ils n'ont même jamais
envisagée et c'est la perspective
du  de l'autre côté, je vais livrer la
dynamique d'insulte du Lee War Office, nous sommes toujours en train de
mettre et de garder un œil sur votre sac si
j'étais vous pendant cent ans, nous avons
appelé cette bataille Gallipoli mais les
Turcs l'appellent l'argile de porcelaine et après un
cent  des années, je pense que nous devrions le
savoir et c'est devenu une chose maintenant que
cela va faire partie de ce qui est enseigné dans les
écoles, mais jusqu'à ce film, ce n'était pas
avant ce film, nous n'avons même jamais utilisé le
mot envahi, vous savez quelle est la chance d'
adorer les garçons  sommes-nous aujourd'hui, ils
ont été tués, je connais la région là-bas, nous
le savons tous les deux, mais plus tout changer
pour un père, il ne peut pas rester en place car
il est le seul père qui est venu garder, nous
pensons toujours à cela en termes de
Britanniques et de  Les Français ont dit aidez-nous à
nous défendre en Europe et c'est devenu
le mouvement sociétal vous savez, les jeunes
hommes lèvent la main et continuent vous savez
ce qui leur était partiellement dur
en tant qu'aventurier vous savez leur
opportunité de voyager à travers le monde
et de ne pas avoir à payer  pour cela et
bien sûr les rapports commencent à revenir
du front combien d'entre eux
meurent et de quelle manière ils sont
morts et c'est brutal et deux familles
se réunissent pour organiser un mariage une
jeune fille leur sert du café  ee si c'est des
épinards je préfère le match s'il est
amer Oh personnellement très bien propre
alors pourquoi les deux vis un vicaire âne
mec ouais vous pourriez tous partager elle est tombée
sur le plan choisi si je m'allongeais sur était la
seule famille ce serait facilement
utilement la tradition est sur nous savons
depuis longtemps parce que dans le
mouvement polyphène Papa Joe ouais bébé
termine enfin plus c'était pour moi qui est le
Turc une chanson l'assassin a anéanti la moitié de
mon bataillon
nous avons trouvé ses fils bons bons et Henry
nous avons commencé  pour gagner des prix là-bas,
nous avons remporté le meilleur film de l'Académie australienne
et l'autre jour, nous avons en fait remporté
cinq prix du Film Critics Circle
of Australia maintenant ces vieux
bâtards poussiéreux n'ont pas mentionné mon nom depuis 15
ans ouais
alors pour moi d'être soudainement  de retour dans cette
situation et pour moi personnellement,
je fais de la presse,
vous savez, et j'ai peut-être une décennie maintenant
d'être ce genre de personnage de tabloïd
amusant et c'est comme un moment d'appâtage d'ours
chaque fois que je viens en ville pour que je
su  ddenly être juste en train d'avoir des conversations
avec des gens sur l'art et d'un
point de vue créatif, c'est un [ __ ] de
soulagement
tangu mon prince qui s'assoit sur ce
tapis peut être transporté dans les
airs en un instant
être un réalisateur me donne le contrôle de
ma vie pendant les 25 ans  J'ai travaillé en tant
qu'acteur d'armes à feu Je vais là où se trouve le travail
si le réalisateur veut travailler
avec moi tourne au Maroc Je vais
au Maroc ou n'importe où,
vous connaissez la Pologne ou l'Islande ou n'importe où
vous savez si je fais mes propres films alors
je peux être à la maison j'ai deux enfants vous
savez donc si ce film rapporte un
résultat commercial à ses investisseurs alors
je peux à nouveau réaliser et je peux faire ma
pré-production en  L'Australie et ma
post-production en Australie, donc j'obtiens
deux choses, une liberté artistique totale
et deux, je peux être plus avec mes enfants,
donc il y a beaucoup à
faire, alors assurez-vous de le dire à vos amis
et qu'ils disent à leurs amis que c'est un  bien
parce que c'est un  ll pour les enfants
si vous vous trouvez que dites
-
vous équipe vous